it kind of feels like with uh a lot of
the stories that we've gone through and
stories like this
we call it a controlled demolition
right like the system is intentionally
being destroyed in various ways the
government's been weaponized I mean even
now as we're sitting here laughing with
the IRS being abolished it's another
component of dismantling the machine I'm
sure Luke doesn't care either way I'm
probably excited for it but in other
ways our culture is also being
dismantled that's the dangerous part
we're not we're not raising our kids
properly the kids are being abused
things like that
without proper culture and without uh
proper parenting nothing else matters I
mean it's going to be
it's gonna be apocalyptic I mean the
culture I would say is is majority lost
I mean I'm in Texas I'm a resident Texas
and I'm covering child drag shows uh
every single week I mean so these people
are on video grooming children and
there's no repercussions for what
they're doing simulated sodomy in front
of kids yeah what's the American culture
right now uh twerking seed oils
promoting sodomy promoting uh obesity I
mean you guys saw that picture on
Twitter today where there's those three
models and the one the one on the very
right with the elephant trunks you
literally can't even see her shoes or
with the remainder of them but that's
promoted as healthy mixing cough syrup
with alcohol that's American culture
right now opiates video games yep video
games is a big part of it so one thing
that I've been talking about quite a bit
and I'd love to talk with you Tyler
about it is this book genderqueer
because uh apparently nobody's read it
it's insane apparently numbers right so
uh I've reached out to a handful of
people you'd think would have read it
um prominent critics and uh FairPoint I
didn't read it either what we all knew
in the book was that you've got these
images that are graphic and we're like
okay kids shouldn't be around that and I
think most of us just assumed that the
Memoir stuff is immaterial like if
you're talking about your life how you
grew up I don't care don't show the
graphic stuff to kids then as it turns
out actually
the book itself is it's a horror story
of child abuse and so to go back to what
you're saying you're in Texas and
there's child drag shows the fact that
it's even coming to Texas is alarming
then it goes to Florida
I think people need to read this book
and I've been saying this all day
because I really really do mean it and I
want to make sure I I highlight this I
can't show these images no it'll get
taken no no but it's not even it's not
even the images people know for those
that aren't familiar in this book
there's graphic depictions of adult
activities but in the first page let me
see let's go to page number two three
four
here we go okay so right so actually
page one two
it's a it's it's a little boy and girl
peeing in the in the yard outside and
the first part of the story is how her
parents brought her to a farm and had
her and and the neighbor boy just
relieving themselves in the outside
complete neglect they talk about how
they didn't have proper uh you know like
your immunities yeah there's that
portion about where she gets pulled
aside by her teacher in school because
she smells so bad and has I don't know
if I can say it but basically her period
blood uh in the same pad over and over
again crumbling down her leg but you're
not allowed to talk about that's and
that's marketed in kids libraries so
what this right and what people uh as
we're talking about this stuff fail to
understand is that when I started so
here's what happened I was going through
this because I was trying to show the
Hodge twins the portion where the author
of this book they're giving to Children
is intent attempting to ingest her own
you know genital fluids and uh you know
in order to find that part I have to I'm
like you know what I haven't actually
read read the book I started reading it
and it's a story about how her mother
abused her had her wearing days
even days old she just says I'll read it
she says I'd often wear the same pet for
so long that dried blood turned to dark
crumbles resembling coffee grounds
where was her mom she's no no wonder she
hates herself she was psychologically
abused and traumatized by her mother and
physically she she's in school and it's
in the book she's like the counselor
pulled me aside saying you smell so bad
people are complaining did your mom not
teach you how to take a bath
she didn't know how to shave her legs
you don't got to shave your legs dude I
don't care but at least the parents
could explain to you why women shave
their legs why some don't you can choose
it but she had no idea she couldn't read
until she was 12. is there a dad ever
mentioned in the book yeah and and the
crazy thing is they're depicted as like
these these happy-go-lucky hippies like
hanging around and playing the guitar
when in reality I wouldn't be surprised
if they're drug addicts I'm not kidding
like the idea that she couldn't read
until she was 12. to me is indicative of
parents who are on drugs or even take do
basic necessities and take care of
herself enough so she doesn't stink and
gets pulled aside yeah like hygiene dude
I want you I want you the most basic
thing to understand is proper hygiene
right the reason why I think it's so
important to read through this stuff as
we're looking at like the morbid obesity
with the shoes bulging all of these
things that people would say is like
degeneracy or whatever it's like dude it
starts somewhere it starts with kids
being abused and we see it over and over
again people I'm not telling you to buy
the book but you know you can read it
online and it's it's like I want you to
imagine this a 12 year old kid who can't
read
walking around with crusted blood
between their legs smelling like feces
peeing in the yard covered in hair
that's a wild child and then this person
struggles to social to socialize becomes
completely traumatized and hates
themself you wonder why no surprise this
person is coming out and saying I'm
non-binary I don't want to be like
anybody because in the book she talks
about how she's made fun of how she's
embarrassed and it's like well well no
crap she was being a it's like the
parents may have well just kicked her
out in the yard and locked the door
that's what it sounds like they did she
goes to school and everyone's making fun
of her because she smells like crap and
she's got dried pads in her pants
nightmarish it's a common difference
that these drag shows that I cover too
is I would say 95 to 98 of the time it's
single obese mothers that are bringing
their children to these shows I mean so
they can't even take care of themselves
and that's what I see as a common
reoccurrence or dressing their their you
know male boys up in tutus and dresses I
mean in a lot of my footage I've you
know I've unveiled teachers bringing
their children to this uh talking about
the grooming of their children like it's
a totally okay and acceptable thing I
mean the drag queens literally engage
with these kids on stage say sexual
jokes they do sexual things directly in
front of them and actually involve the
children in it I mean it's a form of
psychological abuse that I've never seen
before I mean this is I don't want to be
covering this stuff but ever since the
Mr misters one really exploded in pride
month uh you know it's like they've
tripled down this community they've
tripled down over and over again and now
I see multiple of them every single week
the most revealing thing about this book
to me is that that graphic image in
question that everybody talks about the
picture of adult activities the main
character the author of this book writes
out it wasn't doing anything for her so
think about this it's a person who's
abused by her parents neglected filthy
uneducated can't read confused about who
she's supposed to be or what life is
like yeah when you when you leave a kid
out in the wilderness and they grow up
they're not going to be able to properly
function she then tries to engage in
we'll just call it Kink and then she's
like hey this actually isn't doing
anything she's clearly confused she
doesn't enjoy what they're telling her
she should enjoy she's completely
desensitized and that's what they do to
a lot of these children at these drag
shows that I go to is they desensitize
kids to sexually explicit content and
simulated sodomy at a young age so then
they grow up and they don't even
understand what they're seeing I mean
I've there's in the Mr misters when the
first one I ever covered the uh there
was a child sitting at the bar he had a
Nintendo DS he had a Rubik's Cube he was
completely uninterested in what was
going on he had two moms with him and
the gay bartender who was serving drinks
over his head literally asked this kid
this kid if he is gay and he says no and
his mother butts in on behalf of him and
says no no no he is gay he's just too
embarrassed to talk about it you know
what's really interesting I want to
mention this too
I'll say it again you got a kid can't
read dried blood peeing in the yard
covered in hair smelling like feces
and people are making fun of making fun
of her look at but then all of a sudden
she meets the queer straight Alliance
and they're like thank you for being
here we love you and she goes yes this
is who I am exactly no surprise it's it
they're the poor person that wrote that
book has been absolutely psychologically
brutalized their whole life and then
they're put in a position where if they
engage with this activist Group which is
what LGBT essentially is especially when
you're dealing with with queer Theory
and stuff
um they get the affirmations that
they've been dying for they get the love
they get the they they get love the
confirmation that they need in their
mind it is it is very typical cult
Behavior find someone that is vulnerable
that is dissatisfied that is that is in
a position that really needs help and
then tell them all the people the reason
that you're unhappy is because of all of
these people it is literally the same
book that every manipulation
manipulative person does and governments
do it you look at what what the Nazis
said you look at what what the Communist
said blame the bourgeoisie blame the
Jews blame the straight people blame the
Christians it's just the same thing and
then think about this once again a kid
who's neglected in all these ways
smelling like crap and then this group
comes and and she explicitly talks about
how she has crushes on boys too like
this is like a normal little girl uh
being abused and then the the qsa says
we're so happy you're here and then
she's smiling and they're like yay we
love you and by the way those people who
made you feel bad are the bad ones
they're the problem and there you go now
all that anger and resentment she felt
it's almost like a kind of sour grapes I
feel bad for because it's like if she
just had someone tell her look girls
shave their legs it's a social custom
you don't have to do it but all the
other girls do so they may make fun of
you if you don't she didn't have that
she writes how she's like I didn't even
understand what was going on why they
were laughing at me I couldn't even read
crazy and then they villainized those
who are laughing at our for being on
social and you know that sucks too to be
completely honest she wrote this I I
believe because it was like a memoir she
calls it a memoir about her life and
like expression of her experience but
like I believe the kids in the book are
under 18 that are experiencing the
simulated sex acts so if I wrote a comic
strip of two 14 year olds having sex
they would call that child I mean I
think you're supposed to call it child
porn I don't know if they're underage in
that portion they never say if it's
underage or not or if they indicate that
they're at that point I think she's in
college and she's like working a job or
something and also drawing of of sexual
images gets dicey about the legality
because there's a there's a artistic
yeah there's and there's there's a type
of anime May called Lolly lollycon that
that pushes the line apparently like so
and there have been like court cases
where they say because it's drawing
Lolly's okay yeah which is creepy and
gross but I mean you know it is what it
is I don't know that that's illegal but
a lot of these books that are being
actually marketed in children's
libraries do have what you know rational
people would call child porn in them I
mean it has depictions of naked little
girls naked little boys engaging in
certain things I mean and exploring
their body and I understand you know
maturation right basic maturation we all
took we all took it um but that's
teaching about STDs teaching about how
to be safe it's not teaching about how
to actually engage in sex I mean I'm old
enough to remember when they used to
tell you to abstain from sex so you
didn't you know contract these STDs or
go through these terrible experiences
and now I mean books like this are being
marketed to children on a daily basis in
almost every single state of the country
thousands of schools she says she's 25
in that oh wow 25 years old in that
particular portion of the book well well
you're right about Lolly porn that's a
big problem of contention on social
media on Twitter though
Elon Musk has been like none of this and
it's legal it's legal in the United
States because you can't prove that it's
a kid even though it looks like a kid
but no they're drawn just like children
yeah intentionally because it is I think
I consider it a form of childhood that's
if you ever go on like the the map
forums right
um which we're gonna call what it is the
pedophile forums I mean they they share
Lolly relentlessly amongst each other
and it's because it's marketed towards a
certain group of people and they know
what they're marketing towards there's
an interesting thing about this too is
when you read that portion it's it's a
very female perspective on sex and it's
funny because the the you know those
individuals writing how they're queer
and all that stuff but I'm like
I think if like as a dude reading that
I'm like yeah that's a woman like I'm
not trying to be a dick or anything I'm
like the thing she's describing about so
you guys remember 50 Shades of Gray and
it was like women Shades of Gray of gray
women loved that book because women and
men experience and stuff very
differently and men are very Visual and
women are very much more imaginative and
that's basically how the book describes
all of this stuff even to the point
where she says she doesn't enjoy any of
it I'm so glad you read it yesterday and
started got that perspective that it's a
kid that was abused that's such an
important part of this it's it's I I I'm
I I can't even begin bro I can't even
begin when I saw this I can't even show
it on camera oh wow yeah oh wow indeed
like you look at this yeah and you're
just like this poor kid man that was the
real person that lived through that
that's so that's that like that is
it's something that I feel like people
that have you know gotten outraged about
that they're outraged at the person for
writing it and it's like it does suck
that they wrote it but remember they're
writing it because they were abused I
don't think it sucks that they wrote it
I think the problem is they're giving it
to kids that's the only problem with
this I I actually think this is really
important because now you can see how
the trauma and abuse leads to this
person being unhappy and depressed and
and talking about how they dread things
and how they fear things and as adults
we need to understand what's causing
these things to happen so we can help
people the problem is they're putting in
front of kids
that's messed up yeah I mean a lot of
this is uh emotional manipulation
there's a reason a lot of Disney movies
start off with either a parent character
or main character dying off in the
beginning because that trauma is very
powerful to ingrain a lot of different
ideas the CIA started to experiment with
certain things especially when they were
starting to do MK Ultra mind control uh
tests on a lot of human beings causing
them trauma fragmenting their
personalities and brains and then
implementing a new one to see how far
they could actually impact someone with
the ideas that they wanted to put inside
of them so I think trauma is a key
element to all of this that we have to
really understand for for how it's being
used here because you lay out the trauma
and then you of course you have the
problem the new course you have the
solution the solution is you got to join
at this group this group's going to take
you in it's those people that are bad
those people that are responsible for
all the bad things in this world don't
take personal responsibility just join
the cult everything will be fine and
those ideas are being ingrained into
small children when they're in school
they're being indoctrinated into the
cult into the statist Communist larger
ideology and then they're kind of you
know acting like the way that they are
very uh emotionally triggered
individuals that of course are being
used and manipulated by the state that
is using their trauma Their Fear their
emotions for their own personal gain
yeah trauma is the easiest way to I
would say hypnotize people I mean
because you can use that term yeah I
mean whether it's you know there are
trauma can have good responses there are
good trauma responses but that's very
rare but when you're experiencing Trauma
from such a young age like all these
children that are being exposed to these
shows and to these sexually explicit
content on purpose it's completely
intentional because it fragments their
mind just like you said look thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time